a novel virus causes panic stinging
insects swarm america and riots in the
streets pit people versus the police it
happened in 2020 and the simpsons knew
about it all in 1993.
cartoon networks johnny bravo followed
the buff blonde womanizer through
various exploits adventures and mishaps
in one of the best kids shows of the
1990s
if santa doesn't get these letters by
tonight i might not get all those free
presents i asked for in the episode
chain gang johnny which aired on april
27 2001 johnny goes to the movies with
his acquaintance carl the two get into
an argument over the film and if you
look to carl's side you'll notice an
image of a building on fire as the scene
pans over we see the words coming soon
plastered on the poster oh you will pay
for this seeing how the episode aired
less than five months before september
11 2001 some have come to see the
cartoon as an eerie vision of the future
the actual answer is likely a bit
anticlimactic buildings on fire are
nothing new to the world of action
movies and it's likely the image merely
functioned as an homage to something
like the towering inferno it's also
worth pointing out that there's only one
building depicted in the advertisement
instead of the two buildings that would
make for the twin towers so if you were
thinking this was a real prediction well
close
nice try though in addition to johnny
bravo the simpsons has also found itself
at the center of 9 11 prediction
theories thanks to one scene from a
classic episode
[Music]
stupid city what the hell is this thing
in season nines the city of new york
versus homer simpson the family decides
to travel to the big apple to retrieve
homer's car when discussing how they
could possibly afford such a trip lisa
holds up a magazine promotion saying how
there are rides to new york for just
nine dollars right next to the price is
the silhouette of the twin towers it
almost looks as though the cover reads 9
11. it's enough to make you want to get
a hold of the simpsons writers and ask
them how they knew
here's a better idea you give me your
address and i'll write to you uh okay i
just sent it to
jesus uh here is the pentagon it seems
like all it takes to make a 911
prediction is two towers that look
similar and an airplane that's precisely
what you have with the classic bugs
bunny cartoon falling hair in it bugs
goes toe-to-toe with a gremlin on the
side of his plane it's up to bugs to
navigate the vessel to a safe landing
which becomes all the more difficult
when he finds himself in the midst of a
massive city at one point the rascally
rabbit approaches two tall buildings
extremely close to one another at the
last second before bugs would make
impact he turns the plane on its side so
that he safely flies between the two
structures considering this cartoon came
out decades before the world trade
center was built we're thinking this is
less of a prediction and more of a weird
thing to notice while you're watching
old cartoons
the simpsons has seemingly predicted
everything from donald trump's
presidency to richard branson going to
space but one of the show's most spot-on
predictions came in the form of the
season 5 episode springfield or how i
learned to stop worrying and loved
legalized gambling legalized gambling is
a bad idea you can build a casino over
my dead body in the episode springfield
becomes its very own atlantic city
complete with a towering casino with
live entertainment one of these shows is
the flamboyant magic of gunter and ernst
in what is a clear parody of performers
siegfried and roy who had a long-running
show in las vegas for many years with
their signature white tigers gunter and
ernst also have a tiger by the name of
anastasia and after a moment when the
tiger remembers what it was like to live
in the tranquility of the jungle it
attacks the two performers the scene
took on new life when in 2003 roy
suffered severe injuries from a tiger
attack in real life fortunately he
managed to pull through from the
incident and the duo would go on to
perform again you know we're having a
party tonight
[Music]
some cartoon predictions aren't super on
the nose but they can still have a
chilling detail that makes you stop and
say
oh
my
god
that's the case with a season eight
episode of american dad where steve and
his friends stumble upon a downed plane
once venturing inside they find a corpse
clutching a script which just so happens
to be for fast and furious seven look
it's signed by randy scott knobson the
guy who wrote all the fast and furious
movies the guys are stoked to get a
glimpse into the future of the high
octane franchise but when viewing the
episode today it's hard not to be
reminded of paul walker's death whose
final posthumous film role was in
furious 7. walker died tragically in a
car crash eerily reminiscent of the
plane crash depicted in the episode as
it just so happens the scene the friends
read from the script heavily involves
walker's character brian o'connor to
make the connection all the more
heartbreaking
it's pretty impressive when a cartoon
predicts a single aspect of the future
it becomes downright bizarre when a
single episode contains multiple
references to an entire year season 4's
margin chains starts off with virtually
everyone in springfield coming down with
the case of a mysterious new disease
known as the osaka flu the novel disease
spread from japan after some factory
workers coughed into a box on its way to
springfield despite the fact this virus
came from japan and coronavirus
initially hailed from china many
couldn't help but see some parallels
especially considering how the rest of
the episode plays out later in the
episode the citizens of the small town
become panicked and turn toward dr
hibbert for guidance he tells them that
he doesn't have anything that can cure
the outbreak and in an ensuing clash
people knock over a box of killer bees
bees aren't hornets but it still
reminded people of the murder hornets
that briefly took over headlines in
2020. eventually the episode culminates
in mass social unrest with protesters
knocking down statues and facing off
with police in the streets gee
that feels familiar
this never would have happened if marge
simpson was here kevin spacey's fall
from grace may have been a little more
predictable to people in hollywood than
it was to the rest of the world after
decades of critically acclaimed
performances the actor was accused by
several men of sexual harassment and
assault sending his career into a
nosedive but the news may not have been
too surprising for anyone who enjoyed
watching early episodes of family guy in
the season 4 episode don't make me over
brian and stewie make a wager ultimately
resulting in stewie running naked
through a mall shouting something
weirdly specific
help i've escaped from kevin spacey's
basement help me
apparently family guy creator seth
macfarlane has a knack for identifying
sexual predators before harvey weinstein
was outed as a criminal sexual predator
mcfarland made a joke at the producer's
expense during an oscar-related telecast
after announcing the nominees for best
supporting actress he joked
congratulations five ladies no longer
have to pretend to be attracted to
harvey weinstein
with that kind of batting average maybe
mcfarland should work less with cartoons
and lean into detective work so what do
we got today boys well it seems like we
got a bit of a crime spree check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]
you